I would fall into Paradox very very
quickly if I start dictating to you how
to be free we all know you can't be
forced to be free but what I could do
instead is ask well in any given
situation how might you increase the
amount of Freedom that's available to
you the whole thing about direct
democracy if it's not voluntary and
spontaneous then it's not direct
democracy so if you invent a new system
and say to everyone this is going to
work you have to do it like this now it
collapses in on itself immediately you
have to start where people are actually
at and respecting them as already
thinking and intelligent beings that
doesn't mean you tolerate anything of
course it's an exchange it's a
discussion democracy is that for me
democracy is not about achieving a
complete consensus and that's the only
means by which it can function it's
actually about how you have conflict
that's creative rather than
[Applause]
catastrophic